and friends of green New Deal is the
idea whose time has come today I'm proud
to announce that the Green Party will
invest 100 billion pounds a year into
climate action over the next decade
[Applause]
this will be the biggest public
investment in decades and let's be clear
this moment demands nothing less to win
world war two we invested in to protect
the future of our country to set up the
NHS we invested to protect the future of
our people now as we prepare for the
century ahead we will invest to protect
the future of this planet what does that
mean it means decarbonizing every single
sector of the economy energy industry
agriculture transport and housing it's
rapidly rolling out renewable energy in
Britain so that we are Net Zero Carbon
by 2030 it straining and reefs killing
and apprenticeships to create hundreds
of thousands of low-carbon jobs so that
we can lift people out of poverty while
transforming our economy it's subsidies
to replenish and restore our natural
world ensuring that our planet's
delicate ecosystems are protected for
our children's and our grandchildren's
future climate scientists have given us
a window of opportunity to take action
on the climate emergency this could be
our last chance to elect a parliament to
keep us below disastrous warming the
climate doesn't care about promises the
environment doesn't care about pledges
what we need is action and the Green
Party has a single most ambitious and
comprehensive plan so go carbon neutral
bio 2030 will delivering social justice
across Britain so accept no imitations
we are the originators and we are the
experts so if your kids were on the
street with the school strikers if you'd
be moved by the climate movement
this is the climate election vote green
this December it's time if not now then
when